I live in New York I moved to New York
City because that city has so much
energy then I learned that city gets its
energy by sucking it out of the people
that live there but I'm originally from
upstate New York the town of Syracuse
good people up there yeah they drink a
lot they don't drink and drive though
they eat themselves sober at the end of
the night I used to work in a bar and
had a wait chart on the wall to help you
figure out your blood alcohol content
and these guys would come up to the
chart gauri let's see if I can drive my
way 170 okay the chart said I could have
four drinks I had nine I gotta get up to
225 so I'm a married man I met my wife
six years ago on the internet I'm amazed
we're still together because she returns
everything she gets online like a big
excitement in our boat is that 13 months
ago me and my wife had a beautiful baby
girl how about that
we named our cheap applause that's their
name Jupiter
it's a lot of fun though and I find it
gets easier as we go like the first two
weeks a newborn is exhausting because of
other adults everybody wants to see your
kid we want to see that baby once the
best time to see the baby like 4:00 a.m.
would be helpful
don't be late we're leaving her by the
door for you so sorry scared straight
program you come home from the hospital
wiped out - I'd never spent time at the
hospital before I've been lucky in that
regard they were there for a couple of
nights you can't get any sleep at the
hospital because of all the people
reminding you to get some rest
how you feeling a little tired well get
some rest
hour later there's some ship changed I
I hear you're tired just get some rest
can I get you anything yeah you got a
deadbolt lock I can install anything but
being a parents great I love it there's
a perk I did not know about if anyone's
thinking about having kids this is the
greatest thing as soon as you have a kid
from then on you get to pretend that
your opinion is more important than
other people's no matter what's going on
I just thought whoa whoa whoa hold on
hey as a father
of a little girl why would you throw a
pass from the one-yard line so I grew up
in a big family I got three brothers and
three sisters and my father's warming up
to us now which is nice yeah we drove
them crazy when we are all in the house
I don't blame the guy he don't want
seven kids we can prove it we should go
on field trips in school we give our dad
the permission slip it's got that
question in case of an emergency
my dad had right do not resuscitate
now my wife is an only child so early in
our courtship she was very interested in
the logistics of a large family and
she's asked me scripts when your whole
family gets together who cooks I go hon
here's the situation my parents are both
Irish Irish parents have a ton of kids
and then they pray that one of them
marries an Italian Irish meal plan right
there and my wife is not Italian my wife
is Jewish which generations ago that
would have been a big thing nobody cares
anymore my friends think it's exotic you
know once once a while someone gets a
little curious it's like your wife's
Jewish huh is she real religious
apparently not I'm a better juvenile and
she can't say that but both our families
got some sports nuts I'm a bit of a
sports nut
I don't go to live events anymore though
because all these new arenas and
stadiums got the gigantic jumbo Tron's
right and that was great until somebody
invented the kiss-cam
that's where the house camera just zooms
in on a couple and they force you to
kiss and scared the hell out of me and
my sister at a Knicks game
that's not skater you want to piss off
this crowd or go to therapy what do you
want to know
you guys are great thanks for having me
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
YouTube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]